welcome to this video part 6 part 6 of
the world championship 2013 appetizing
serious and at some college game again
and let's get going the game i'm going
to show his cards and against greece
shock me shock on top 10 player form
quite a number of years and back then he
also was top ten planets in 2009 the
Narrows 2009 the traditional tournament
in spain and let's get going it's what
do you fall i mentioned Carlton play
some all opening moves but if I was
maybe a bit more common than the others
okay we got a slogan and a night off we
showcase some also we was Italian his
openings but the night off has always
been one of his and his made options
against evil so something that could be
expected there should be two this is in
fact a fairly typical choice for 4,000
he usually does not play them super
aggressive support theoretical lines but
rather lines let them allow you to
postpone the fight for a bit delay it
until the middle game sometimes even the
endgame she does not really want to
participate in a preparation war just
wants to get a position where there are
some tension okay Bishop e2 is some very
traditional move that has been
championed by me if him Geller back into
the 50s 60s and later Geller top this
move home yeah to Anatoly Karpov and
cap-off became the champion of this line
sometimes you even know
we did you read that that some people
call it the cap off or yellow cap of
variation something like that three
sugars playing e6 of course blacks got
the principal choice you can also go to
five the traditional night off route but
in 60 transposes to ask evening and set
up or heavenly to be a bit closer to the
touch pronunciation are probably still
doing it wrong button let's try okay
castles there should be seven a form
yeah a four designed to prevent be 596
there should be three so we see that
white is some castling and developing
pieces first before he starts a direct
attack unlike some other lines where
white pushes in early g4 for example
castles i def for me quincy 7 and ph 1
this is the absolute main line of the
scavenging and nowadays this is given in
with a six there's also version but
black does not play sex obviously you
cannot get it term via the night off
water but if thus giving is reached why
are the five a-six the night of order
you very often get to this position here
black has some a choice the usual move
has rupee eight you can also play now
Bishop d7 but rookie a Chester Nolan and
Bishop to f3 so those two bishops are
nicely positioned they cover the center
and white is preparing further action
and there's some one idea was g4 and g5
attacking on the King said after all and
two there are other ideas get towards
playing a five here Grisha plane
interesting we played Bishop to f8 I
believe this has become popular in
recent years back in the day some in the
1980s
the normal move was rugby aid in fact if
I'm not mistaken this was exactly the
position that was reached in the final
game of the World Championship match
1985 1985's cap off against Kasparov the
twenty fourth game back then they played
24 games that couple had to win in order
to keep the title but he lost and
desperate became the thirteenth world
champion so lots of history and this
some dis lines Bishop f8 is not
committing the loop yet and it's often
useful to have to be Shabbat evade any
way to protect the king size Queen d2
this is one idea to get the Queen
involved Group B H now we have to yeah
this is some now position where white
has developed his pieces he has got
rooks collected and you can think about
further action now however its next turn
what is some good idea here one typical
move is not a five however this is not
good in this some exact position if you
want a small tactical exercise you can
look at this position I'm going to be
silent for a couple of Second Circuit
boss gap the technical solution here is
night xe6 fairly typical this is the
point like we captures the spaceship b6
sent white will win upon with a great
position not to boot so
95 is not possible grigio played 'if
i've also rather common idea once the
rook is on yet you want to play a 52
yeah to give some spoilers on scope to
this piece and here White has a choice
it can also just go back to e2 this is
another move however thousands move from
ft xe5 was another team at this point
and not sure if this really was the
preparation that sir it's possible but
also could be something thought of over
the board I like this means much more
than nice d to e 2 and then while this
shouldn't necessarily give an advantage
it seems more promising to me agree shop
now recaptured with the pawn logical
wants to give some Stoke to the bishop
and keep the position bit long let's say
tidy with to pawn islands however this
wasn't a bad move it's still a fairly
typical structure for the night off
Black has this excellent night on e5 and
it was was playable Bishop g5 was maybe
the move that he was afraid of but the
same isn't so clear black and even play
like the FG for something something like
this is a possibility fairly complicated
stuff it was possible but to take c5 is
not to move that need some or merits any
any criticism 9 p-3 this is what I like
about this changing of structure the
night on b3 seems to me better place
then on e to hear it at least them has
some influence over
square next move night before this is
designed to cover d5 and also get some
cloud to play against c2 so a good move
like also could have played Bishop to e6
covering this critical square um maybe
he didn't like that this queen is a bit
a bit misplaced after that but it's um
it's still an interesting position for
both sides something like this could be
could be played yeah with the double
attack and it's it's really complicated
after C 3 and d 4 they could analyze
this much deeper it's a very complicated
stuff but this wasn't really a mistake
Bishop 287 those little moves very often
are the difference between a market the
difference between a good player and a
very good player so there should be six
as the office move Bishop a7 is just
more precise it gains a tempo on the
rock the Roku needs to save itself and
then you go back and the rock is
somewhat worse on a eight then on be
eight so it's just a little detail but
those little details add up uncle Queen
37 probably the best square and rook 81
note that causal gets all pieces into
play not starting any direct action try
to punish black for whatever I mean
black you didn't really play play
terrible so no reason that punishment is
possible but what I'm going at is about
what I'm getting added such is so a very
good feel for using all his pieces and
setting up a more years position
and I'll be sufficiently six is played
it seems that on this really
normal-looking move as a mistake
surprisingly it seems to be better for
black to play Bishop to g4 and this is
mostly technically I'm justified move
white stakes like the only captures of
course and after Knight f6 we have from
a similar position to the game but
compared to the game night d 5 as much
worse due to this idea in the game we
had Bishop b6 and then 95 and after this
this Bishop wanna three is really strong
black also couldn't really take with the
night also a problem to take with the
night what are you doing now let's say
here and after this move has d6 threat
Black is completely busted it's really a
problem after 95 he took with the bishop
and now White has got this extremely
strong deep all supported by this Bishop
but Bishop did I think as is correct
played in for trying to get some
counterplay d6 attacking the Queen and
now Queen 36 a black isn't role anyway
but it seems that Queenie 5 was made a
bit more tenacious it allows this heaven
or cave but
f3 is also something like this is the
line that you would need to examine f6
and now 1984 it's equal material
curiously enough but white has these
active pieces so wyd is better but black
still hangs on it's a big threat here so
black probably needs to do something
like this I'm not sure maybe this one
there it's fairly complicated but white
has an extra porn this is something and
he's got the look on the 7th widest
better the black is not dead in the game
after Queen e6 it gets very very
critical but the nice thing about this
game is the finishing touches these are
very nice 95 taking the Queen going to
f5 and the bishop closet echt drops back
so we got a queen trade and still
there's this extremely strong bond 9v to
d5 and here Carter makes slide on
slightly inaccurate move the only only
slight collision scam which led a 5 this
still preserves some advantage but it's
not the best move it seems that rock f6
is the best very forceful like needs to
recapture and after that you go a five
and then d7 and this is very strong like
that it shows a nice picture of
domination being an exchange down but
all those pieces work perfectly together
yeah white is winning here 937 coming so
this was very strong he played a five
and here after the capture he agree show
of Bishop Bishop could have retained a
playable game still being in slight
trouble but it would have been would
have been a fight he now needs to play
look to c 8 activating the rook white
goes before probably if you take on me
seven like will capture on c2 and get
activity there's also this one I mean
also this move like you also try that
this is not good before us better oops
not not like that this is what I'm
getting it this is a bit better and
after for example Roxy 687 oops
butchered my notes here would be seven
oops ah that's 97 and you can do that
but it's not clear that it's really a
check really helping check and the game
store continues its not a forced win
black hangs on a bit after ox yet here
however you played rugby eight probably
being in time travel we shook being
Jewish oak is always in time trouble um
yep and what's now maybe you can try to
work it out what move now is improving
why its chances considerably waiting for
bit here yeah
move as the exchange stack just take on
F 697 this is strong it's introducing
this idea which also would pick up the
exchange getting it back also attacking
the rook and all in all this night is
such a terribly um stunning pc edit it
really keeps like some play clocked up
yeah I played f5 the relatively best
choice and and now this is some quite
instructive this night is so strong
there's no need ready to to take on be
aid you can first easily place you form
like it's completely tied up 85 and c5
just very strong let's say instead of a
five black would have played rock the
eight just just show it check then this
check then this will win in the long run
this will end similarly to the game and
i'm not going to show it because this is
very beautiful so c5 and Bishop g7 this
was played and car took on b8 look be
eight and this position is really a very
good exercise white play and win it's
some there's not only one way to win but
there is a very efficient way to win and
also it's a very visual very pleasing
move to play so I'm going to be silent
for a couple seconds that you can pause
the video and look for yourself try to
calculate this
yeah the winning move on to very elegant
one and some Bishop to a six very nice
just getting to this week Colin b7 and
trying to capture it and yeah of course
that could take the call if it takes
there's this one and those three pawns
decide and wide will promote this is
just a very nicely played we should
basics I always like this this moves
that are sort of bouncing from the from
the side and then back it's a bit of a
billiards move playing the bishop to the
a fun and then it bounces to to be 72 to
lend very nice similar like we should h5
to accept this would be a similar way
always like the aesthetics of that so um
what is were threatening it just to take
and then after Bishop f6 why just took
on b7 and use the pawns three connected
a sports a bit much however an important
thing after rupee six what should I play
if you go see six lakh will stop the
pulse need to be precise this is the
right move giving this upon the extra
support it needs took on b2 and now d 7
and that's it gree shock here reside b8
queen is absolutely unstoppable for
instance after Bishop 6 c 7 and then
there's depending on the circumstances a
new queen for white and the Queen even
stays on the bottom so it's an extra
Queen for nothing
it's not a particularly difficult finish
but I always found it very very pleasing
to the eye getting rid of this
blockading piece entering and then in a
very straightforward manner the pawns
are pushed and just when you think okay
maybe black can hold on a bit he lay
there no bishop here and its opposite
colored bishops then there's this blow
bishop a6 just Lamech peace bishop asics
taking and then the pawns decide the
game very nicely played and it also
shows that counts and likes to play
those harmonious type of position where
where you have all your piece develop
their or work nicely note that in this
game or pieces played and they all play
it in a way that they had some function
you should Bend whoops Bishop and night
obviously the roofs were working in
sacrificing and supporting the porn so a
very harmonious and straightforward game
yeah and also at the opening and if we
see night off it's possible and place
the night off maybe we will see but
should be too from Magnus never know but
uh nuns also an expert on we should be
too so you will never know what is going
to happen alright I hope you like the
game thanks for watching